[Music]
anti-semitism hiding in plain sight
that's the focus of tonight's angle
during the next several months we at the
Ingraham angle are going to devote a
significant amount of time unpacking the
most important political and cultural
stories of the day our aim is that these
investigations help you better
understand the people and facts behind
critical challenges facing you your
family and our country tonight we
examine the pernicious influence in
American politics of this woman Linda
Sarsour a woman described by the New
York Times very affectionately as a home
girl in a hijab I am a Palestinian
Muslim American activist born and raised
in Brooklyn and every Islamophobes worst
nightmare sponsored by Mercedes well she
is a nightmare period a relentless
self-promoter she represents so much
that is hideous now check out this
attack on the Trump administration where
Sarsour actually invokes jihad I hope
that we when we stand up to those who
oppress our communities that we are
struggling against tyrants and rulers
not only abroad in the Middle East or on
the other side of the world but here in
these United States of America where you
have fascists and white supremacists and
Islamophobes reigning in the White House
reigning in the White House she's also
extremely subtle now as the co-founder
of the anti-trump women's march in
January 2017 so soar became a
near-constant fixture in the media
spewing her hate and her lies everywhere
now wherever there's a camera you'll
find her trying to hog it as she did in
the Kavanagh confirmation fight even
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and a bad chanter she was arrested
during the hearings themselves but so
were a lot of other leftist agitators
she wore it as a badge of honor yes arse
or who claims to stand for all these
oppressed people all over the world and
has even done some fundraising for
victims of anti-jewish violence is
really an anti-semite herself hiding in
plain sight
Saur Saur and two other founders of the
Woman's March Tameka Mallory and Carmen
Perez have all appeared at events
sponsored by the sickeningly
anti-semitic organization the Nation of
Islam including by the way one way or
ericon himself said the Jews are my
enemies now any Association whatsoever
with Farrakhan is the ultimate tell
regarding someone's true motives when
they talk about Farrakhan call me a
hater you know what they do call me an
anti-semite stop it I'm anteater might
the Jews don't like Farrakhan so they
call me hidden well that's a good name
Hitler was a very great man in Farrakhan
by God's grace has pulled
let's see of course a perfunctory
condemnation of anti-semitism or other
forms of bigotry it was issued by
Sarsour and her cohorts cohorts but
they've yet to condemn Farrakhan himself
last spring the woman's March
organizations cited the difficult and
often painful work of intersectional
movement-building hence why they had to
work with him and instead of a strong
unequivocal condemnation of the Nation
of Islam founder they wrote Minister
Farrakhan statements about the Jewish
queer and trans people are not aligned
with the women's March unity principles
oh that's tough but now to quote another
well-known anti-semite the chickens are
coming home to roost
the main founder of The Woman's March
Teresa shook wants the Saur Saur Mallory
Perez trio to step aside even that nasty
Trump hater Alyssa Milano is less than
charmed she's threatening to boycott the
next woman's March coming up in just a
couple months unless Sarsour and company
leave the organization but my question
is what took him so long Saur Saur of
course feigned an apology but she's not
backing down from her harsh attacks on
Jews just a few weeks ago on Facebook
she slammed folks who masquerade as
progressives but always choose their
allegiance to Israel over their
commitment to democracy and free speech
now the phrase allegiance to Israel is a
favorite among the anti-semitic set to
his credit CNN's Jake Tapper was all
over Sarsour last spring after the
woman's March wished a cop-killer
fugitive who fled to Cuba a happy
birthday the venomous Sarsour responded
with this Jake Tapper joins the ranks of
the alt-right to target me online
aside from tappers Twitter takedown
media outlets including CNN were
responsible for elevating Saur Saur to
cult-like status so desperate to smash
all things chomp the the left was all
- happy to offer this incendiary figure
a platform to organize we're coming back
out and we're announcing today to the
American people to join us around the
country and in Washington DC on January
19 2019 we are outraged that we are
talking about and putting victims on
trial and talking about dr. Ford in the
way in which she was treated at that
hearing unreal but today some good news
CNN dump contributor mark Lamont Hill
after he delivered a speech at the UN
that seemed a call for wiping the State
of Israel off the map Lamont Hills
association with the network was
especially ironic given the network's
new series at CNN about the rise of
anti-semitism here and abroad
Saur Saur owes her public profile to a
press that has gone out of its way to
cover for her rather than actually cover
her true motives and allegiances they
made excuses for Sarsour because she's a
woman she's Muslim and she's a harsh
critic of the president now they're
paying the price with further erosion in
their own credibility and that's the
angle